l'amour est dans le pré hier soir 4,2
millions de téléspectateurs mais oui les
gars ça calme tout le monde là on a
envie de dire bravo m6 terminé merci m6
il commence un petit peu à nous à nous
gonfler un peu un joli voilà si m6 nous
regardent aussi s'il commence alors je
les aimais bien là mais ils vont pas
tarder à recevoir un coup de fil alors
on a demandé des invités là les gens de
l'amour est dans le pré c'est non non
j'en ai marre conseiller c'est non alors
je m'adresse le grand patron de m6 ça va
chier des bulles mais ça va pas se
passer comme monsanto et de lundi non
nicolas tarnaud qui est un ami nicolas
si tu pouvais dire à tes amis la queue
ici c'est toujours on les recevra très
bien t'inquiète pas dans les règles de
sécurité ils seront rejoint le remettra
un petit caprice des tubes
voilà du baby beel des trucs quoi ils
font même du doigt la dalle voilà c'est
pas moi de la pâte à modeler avec des
morceaux de babybel voilà on va bien les
recevoir alors j'espère qu'on aura des
gens m6 prochainement
en tout cas moi ils vont nous enlever ça
il y avoue alors on veut vraiment des
gens d'affaires veut plus de gens de m6
merci je vous propose de regarder avec
cap de l'épisode derrière avant de
revenir en plus en détail sur ce qui a
marqué les téléspectateurs
et même si ça a cartonné il ya des gens
qui ont dit que c'est un petit peu trop
cucul et son la praline regardez
c'est hier que karine lemarchand
commencé à refermer progressivement le
rideau sur cette quinzième saison de
l'amour est dans le pré avec la première
partie du bilan
je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
pour les pilotes de cette quinzième
saison de l'amour est dans le pré
ça n'aura échappé à personne cette
saison a été placée sous le signe de la
légèreté de la gaudriole
les blacks plus lourdes les unes que les
autres et très axée en dessous de la
ceinture
un casting avec des personnages
atypiques comme eric cet agriculteur qui
a marqué les esprits par ses
comportements un peu machiste soirée
saison qui a été marquée par les
mécanismes de jeu souvent trop marquée
sans compter des couples aux relations
souvent sur jouer je suis tôt du côté
des audiences karine peut tout de même
se féliciter puisque les téléspectateurs
étaient 4,4 millions hier devant le
programme deuxième partie du bilan lundi
prochain alors trop cucul fake
comprenez vous les critiques sur la
saison de l'amour est dans le pré alors
comprenez vous les critiques sur
l'émission l'amour est dans le pré
isabelle bien entendu notre magnifique
n'ont alors pas du tout parce que par
exemple au couple un petit peu phare de
l'émission jérôme et lucile des trophées
avec des trop cucul comme on l'a dit
alors que non ils s'aiment vraiment un
mais on l'a rapproché sur twitter ils
ont répondu à ça en disant ça s'appelle
tout simplement le coup de foudre
mais les six mois après il fait toujours
le parfait amour et ils disent qu'on ne
peut pas comprendre à partir du moment
où on ne vit pas une expérience comme
celle qu'ils ont vécu et ils sont
toujours ensemble et il sait ça
s'appelle le moose alors justement le
coup de foudre on va en parler du
maraîcher du rhône à jérôme avec lui si
la bretonne
une idylle qui avait commencé lors du
speed dating puisque les toutous retour
où on dirait que tu es un coup de foudre
l'un pour kate j'ai eu un coup de foudre
ici moi castaldi mais comment vous
faites avec vos yeux c'est un coup de
foudre c'est quoi ce à l'oreille
vous avez en outre poursuit mais que moi
quelle femme une deux trois quatre ans
avec avec raiponce et comme je vois pas
bien vous le savez monsieur aurait fait
sur le plateau de secret story en rond
on s'est rapprochés comme ça et j'ai vu
que vous êtes de près on s'est embrassé
comme ça directement sans faire exprès
massy arm sotelo 20 ans et je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui c'était gérable
non pas du très bon le parti ça va je
suis ravi de te rencontrer moi aussi
carrément carrément ça se joue surtout
nombreux regards en fait et la chantera
noël je saute
[Rires]
key
quand je les ai vus j'ai eu l'impression
que j'avais rencontré l'homme de ma vie
en fait ça m'a fait vraiment un drôle
d'effet
[Musique]
voila voila moi moi moi je vous le dis
je le dis aucun spectateur j'ai pas peur
de le dire quitte à fâcher des gens
quitte à choquer même jeunes amoureux de
l'amour et je vais choquer ce soir oui
alors et alors il va avoir des titres un
blog de jean marc morandini
cyril hanouna urgent est un amoureux de
l'amour y est alors s'il faut que je
prenne des impôts que je les prendrai
d'ailleurs je les raconte
aujourd'hui j'ai dit haut et fort tout
ce que les gens me disent tout bas
oui iv novelli alors on leur reproche
d'être trop sexuel voilà leur reprochent
d'être trop larmoyant ont leurs
ressources d'être passé naturel on leur
reproche énormément de choses donc là on
leur reproche d'être trop cucul c'est
logique et ben non c'est la vie dans la
ville ya du sexe il ya dès qu il ya des
il se passe plein de choses donc je vois
pas de quoi encore on en est là alors
proposé l'amour est dans le pré c'est un
petit peu de télé réalité suite au speed
dating à jérôme caby donc lucile dans
son exploitation et très vite le couple
conclure comme nous le fait comprendre
giro mais là apparemment il ya eu des
chiens peu ce qui est papa dans maman
[Rires]
à deux ils suffisent et ça fait
longtemps que ce n'était pas arrivé donc
courte mais intense
je garde pour moi énorme et papa comment
te dire
un peu court mais intense alors rsa
voilà oui je radina mais kenya raison on
veut du cul cul et on veut du cul tout
alors le cul cul on là parce qu'il ya
les centimes enseignants y enseigner le
che bien et puis on veut quand même du
passage à l'acte
socom c'est une émission télé réalité
que je déteste par ailleurs je déteste
ce programme ben voilà on en a pour
notre argent et le rapport par rapport
aux petites histoires de fait alors le
seul qui sont là les deux seuls qui se
fait c'est benjamin et bernard montiel
salut berna salut je me plaigne qu'on
appelle tout c'est quoi ton problème
les seuls que j'ai vraiment aimé
justement c'est la relation lucile et
jérôme parce qu'elle est très belle mais
tout le reste est tellement scénarisé
mais nous mêmes et pas du tout les deux
jeunes femmes gaieté vieux d'autrefois
qui re découvre l'amour avec un homme
monsieur handicapées qui dès hier donc
se laisser finir bernard monter ça fait
25 ans que c'est pareil il est à
bruxelles at et régions françaises non
mais je tiens pas à m'exprimer à voir la
fin de l'émission
alors il ya des gens qui ont été gênés
par voilà par une scène les deux
amoureux sont vraiment accros l'un à
l'autre à tel point qu'ils finissent
même par m karine lemarchand mal à
l'aise et m karine lemarchand mal à
l'aise c'est videront oui c'est à ça
qu'on les reconnaît
mais pas savoir à quel point vous ne
pouvez pas savoir à quel point
à quel point c'était parfait c'est tu
peux pas t'imaginer ricard petit état qu
elle est incroyable elle est fantastique
enfin je merci quoi
[Musique]
mais je vais te dire tout simplement je
t'aime
g
[Musique]
c'est génial je suis pas du tout
d'accord mais je le kiffe les deux ah
oui
tous les deux ils sont très bons à bonal
or sagen karine lemarchand moi c'est son
problème est la plus marrante et parce
que je m'en fous qu'il s'agit de karine
le marchand
mais les deux ne me gêne pas du tout moi
je les attends je les trouve magnifique
mais oui nicolas pernikoff moi j'aurais
trouvé ce programme formidable pour
france 3 on va vers les gens
on va vers les régions les agriculteurs
quoi être très mal leur vie il sera
équipé de tout est là l'amour va vers
basse bien son histoire me down il faut
arrêter de penser en permanence je suis
allée scénarisé que ses doigts la
latéralité co2 sont déjà renseignés
qu'il soit trop de thalassa mais comment
il rencontre des gens dire à clamer haut
d'une truite comment il rencontre des
gens les agriculteurs aujourd'hui grâce
à la gourde ondemand vachement ainsi
deux rencontres pour agriculteurs oui
mais on sait qu'on y sent pas compris
tout alors ils sont passés ce qui est
vrai pardonnez moi c'est que je vous
savez le monsieur eric dans le temps
s'est beaucoup moqué qui était torse
poil 1 et bien il a dit il ya une vraie
chaîne d'amitié c'est à dire que les
agriculteurs entre eux qui souvent sont
isolés ce contact se voit se revoient
l'iphone des parties de pêche
moi je hais ce fils de foin quand y'en a
un casier dans la dèche moi c'est ça que
je trouve le mieux dans l'amour est dans
le pré en corse est très bonne et une
des meilleures une des trois meilleures
de ces dernières données
nous lient au bas mot obama